هولندا تعتزم تشكيله حالف من دون المانيا
لارسال دبابات ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا
وزراء وخارجيه اوروبا يبحثون اليوم قائمه
جديده من العقوبات على مسؤولين ايرانيين
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في اسلام اباد
ومدن اخرى بسبب عطل كبير في الشبكه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
البدايه من موسكو وفي مؤشرين عالم فراجه
ربما في العلاقات بين روسيا وامريكا كشفا
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروب
عن وصول السفير الامريكي الجديد الى موسكو
خلال الايام القليله القادمه وذلك وفقا
لوكاله انباء انتر فاكس الروسيه كما اوضحت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان الوضع الراهن لا يسمح
بجدوله اجتماع من شانه وضع بدايه جديده
لموسكو واشنطن الخارجيه الروسيه اضافت
انها تواصل مناقشه القضايا المتوتره مع
السفير الامريكي الجديد لدى موسكو
وبخصوصي ازمه تسليم الدبابات الالمانيه
ليوبارد لاوكرانيا التي تتجه لخلق ازمه
معلنه بين برلين وارسو شدد رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ماتيوز موراوسكي على ان امتناع
المانيا عن التعاون بشان التزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات ليوبارد سيتبعه انشاء تحالف دولي
لا يضم برلين وذلك بهدف تسليح اوكرانيا
بالدبابات في الزراعه الوقت
الالمانيه بان اوكرانيا تنزف ولم يسمح
بمشاهدتها حتى تموت على حديقه
الموقف في برلين لا يزال غامضا فبينما قال
وزير الدفاع الالماني ان القرار بشان
تزويد كييف بدبابات ليوبار سيتم اتخاذه
قريبا اوضحت وزيره الخارجيه ان ليبيغ بوك
ان بلادها لن تقف في طريق هولندا اذا
ارسلت الاخيره دبابات ليو بارت 2 لالمانيا
او المانيه الصنع الى اوكرانيا واضافت بيغ
بوك انه اذا مضت وارز قدما في ارسال
دبابات ليوبارد من دون موافقه المانيا فلن
نقيفه في طريقها
وقبل ذلك استقبل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكغون المستشار الالماني اولف جلد في
باريس وذلك لاحياء الذكرى الستين لمعاهده
الاليزيه التي ارسلت المصالحه بين البلدين
ما اكون اكد ان باريس لا تستبعد تسليم
دبابات لوكلير القتاليه الثقيله لاوكرانيا
لدعمها في الحرب ضد روسيا
لم يتعهد الرئيس الفرنسي بارسال دبابات
لكلر القتاليه الشهيره الى اوكرانيا لكنه
لم يستبعد ذلك وشكل ما قاله تطورا نسبيا
في موقف باريس تحدث عن معايير محدده
ستراعى في حال ارسال هذه الدبابات
تصعيديه وان تؤمن هذه الدبابات دعما
حقيقيا وفعليا لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين
اما المستشار الالماني الذي توقع ان تستمر
الحرب في اوكرانيا لفتره طويله جدا فقد
بقي جوابه غامضا بشان احتمال تزويد
لم يقدم سلاحا لدول التي تعيش النزاعات من
دون نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه لكننا
غيرنا سياستنا بالتنسيق خصوصا مع امريكا
وفرنسا ودول اوروبيه اخرى
تحدث لنا عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
والدفاع في مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي جيل
بالرجاء عن ضروره ارسال دبابات قتاليه
لحمايه اوكرانيا ومن خلفها كل اوروبا
مسيرات الايرانيه وارسال الدبابات قادره
على التحرك السريع
جاء سلبيان الختامي والاعلان المشترك
الفرنسي الالماني ان البلدين حريصان على
شراكه اطلسيه قويه كلام يعكس تقارب
اللفظيا بين باريس وبرلين فيما الخلافات
حول قضايا الدفاع والطاقه ما زالت كامله
براي مراقبين الازمه الصامته بين قطبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي الرئيسيين تمحورت اولا
حول تباين حاجتين الى الغاز الروسي وثانيا
حول عدم وجود رؤيه دفاعيه اوروبيه مشتركه
ذهبت برلين بعيدا عن باريس اولا نحو الصين
ثم نحو الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى في حلف
النيته وكاد تتعاون حتى مع اسرائيل حول
منظومه صاروخيه حذر نكره المانيا من ان
تعزيل نفسها اوروبيه فتراجعت في الشكل
واللهجه على الاقل حسين قنيبر العربيه من
قصر الاليزيه باريس
هذا واحد مشرعون امريكيون اداره الرئيس
جاوبيدن على تصدير دبابات ابرامز اموان
القتاليه الى اوكرانيا قائلين ان ارسال
عدد رمزي منها سيكون كافيا لتشجيع الحلفاء
الاوروبيين على فعل ذات الامر وقال مايكل
عضو عضو الحزب الجمهوري للجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في مجلس النواب قال ان دبابه
واحده فحسب من دبابات ابرام ستكون كافيه
لتشجيع الحلفاء وخصوصا المانيا على ارسال
دبابات دعما لاوكرانيا في قتاليه ضد روسيا
اما سيناتور الديمقراطيه كرسكونس فقال انه
انا الالوان لتنحيه المخاوف جانبا ومواصله
العمل مع حلفائنا المقربين والمضيء قدما
في تزويد بالدبابات
تصاعد الحديث عن تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
في الاونه الاخيره لكنك تتمسكوا بدبابات
ليوبارد الالمانيه اكثر من تمسكها بدبابات
ابرامز امريكيه او غيرها لماذا هذا
الاصرار الاوكراني الاجابه نتبعها
خيبه امل الاوكرانيه بعد ما فشلت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باقناع برلين لارسال دبابات
ليوبار اليها رغم الضغوط الدوليه الداخليه
ولكن لماذا تتمسك اوكرانيا بدبابات
اليوبار الالمانيه اكثر من ابرامز
الامريكيه هذه الدبابات مشاهدينا تعد
الاقوى في العالم بعد ابرامز الامريكي
تشغيلها وصيانتها اسال بكثير من الدبابات
الامريكيه التي تحتاج الى وقود طائره اما
الدبابات الالمانيه الصنع فتحتاج الى
الديزل لتشغلها
وتقتصد اكثر في المصروف نتحدث عن الطاقه
من الدبابه الامريكيه وفق الخبراء
العسكريه لا يطير الالمانيه هي ايضا اخف
وزنا واسرع حركه ويمكنها ان تصيب اهداف
ادق وابعد من ابرز وهذا الامر اشار اليه
واشنطن سابقا عندما قالت ان الصعوبات
التقنيه هو سبب الرئيسي لرفض ارسال واشنطن
لدبابات
دبابات لايوبارت 2 بدا تصنيعها عام 1979
في المانيا الغربيه كدبابات قتال رئيسيه
يمكنها التصدي للدبابات السوفياتيه طبعا
ايام الحرب البارده التقديرات العسكريه
مشاهدينا تشير الى وجود نحو
1150 دبابات ليوبار لدى الدول الاوروبيه
من بينها طبعا المانيا فيما تطالب
اوكرانيا ب100 من هذه الدبابات وتقول انها
ستكون كافيه لردع الهجوم الروسيه وشنها
جمال لاستعاده الاراضي الاكرانيه دول
البلقتين
واستونيا وليتوانيا وجهه دعوه مشتركه الى
المانيا لارسال الدباباتها الرئيسيه الى
اوكرانيا لمساعده اكياس طبعا في حربها ضد
روسيا ولكنها برين تتخوف من رد فعل روسيه
امكانيه ان تعتبر روسيا ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى كاف تصعيدا في الحرب مما يت
طبعا باذى لالمانيا مباشره لقد يعرضها
لانتقام روسيا
في ذات السياق اعلن نائب وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي ان السلطات الايطاليه والفرنسيه
بصدد استكمال العمل لارسال انظمه الدفاع
الجوي
الى اوكرانيا
صواريخ جاهزه للاطلاق
مصممه لحمايه ساحه المعركه والمواقع
التكتيكيه الحساسه
تتمتع بقدره تغطيه تبلغ 360 درجه للاكتشاف
والاشتباك
لديها قدرات مواجهه بعض هذه الاهداف على
الارتفاعات الشديده الانخفاض
توفر قدره حقيقيه ضد الصواريخ والطائرات
مخصصه لمواجهه الاهداف في بيئه التشويش
الالكترونيه المعقده
عام 1990 بدات تطوير منظومه سام تي
في 2013
ناشونال الايطالي والفرنسي منظومه سام تي
داخل بنيه حلف الناتو للمره الاولى
عن وصول عدد الاطفال القتلى جراء الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا الى نحو 460 طفلا منذ
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي
حتى اليوم النيابه العامه الاوكرانيه
اوضحت ايضا ان عدد المصابين من الاطفال
وصل الى نحو 900 جريح
مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
اعلامي حدادا على ضحايا مجزره كاليفورنيا
والشرطه تواصل التحقيق
احييكم من جديد يجتمع اليوم مجلس الشؤون
الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي لمناقشه توصيات
البرلمان الاوروبي بفرض عقوبات جديده على
ايران
والدور الذي تلعبه في دعم العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا ويدور
الكثير من الجدل حول الاجتماع
قوه الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب بعد
تصويت البرلمان الاوروبي لصالح القرار
ورفع تصويته الى مجلس الاتحاد ومن المقرر
ان تشهد بروكسل احتجاجات للايرانيين على
هامش الاجتماعي للمطالبه بادراج الحارس
الثوري على قائمه الارهاب
نشير مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل من
الاستخبارات الروسيه حيث يقولون بان
اوكرانيا قد تفجر عمدا مستودعات ذخيره
خزنتها في محطات طاقه نوويه اذا اتهامات
من الاستخبارات الروسيه بانها اوكرانيا قد
تفجر عمدا مستودعات ذخيره النوويه نعود
الى نشرتنا حيث ان الغضب من سلوك لا يقتصر
على المسؤولين الاوروبيين وانما حتى من
عامه المواطنين حيث تجمع المئات من
البلجيكيين وسط العاصمه بروكسل للمطالبه
بالافراج عن المواطن المعتقل في ايران
وقالت
ناتالي شقيقه فانديكاستيل المعتقل انها
تحدثت وعائلتها مع اوليفيا الجمعه الماضيه
حيث اخبرهم بانه اوقف الاضراب عن الطعام
وانه فقد نحو 25 كلغ من وزنه
قبل ذلك هددت وزاره الاستخبارات الايرانيه
الاوروبيين باستهداف مصالحهم في اسيا اذا
صنفت الحرس الثوري تنظيما ارهابيا وقالت
الوزاره انها تمتلك معلومات سريه بانهاء
الاوروبيين للمرحله الاولى من تصنيف الحرس
الثوري كنظيما ارهابي وحذرت وزاره
الاستخبارات الايرانيه الدول الاوروبيه من
انها ستقوم بالرد بالمثل في حاله الصدر
القرار الذي تعتبره يتعارض مع الامن
القومي للنظام الايراني
وكانت قد اعلنت منظمه ايران لحقوق الانسان
ان احد المعتقلين في الاحتجاجات الاخيره
دخل في غيبوبه بسبب اصابته بجروح اثناء
الاعتقال ووفقا المنظمه فان المعتقل حسن
فيروزي عان من نزيف حاد بعد التعذيب
والضرب على ايدي المحققين فيروزي حسب
المنظمه فقد كليته اليسرى بسبب التعذيب
ولم يتم تقديمه اي علاج له في غضون ذلك
قال محامي معتقل محمد اختياران في خرم
اباد غرب ايران موكله سقط في غيبوبه ايضا
نتيجه اصابته بجروح اصيب بها اثناء
الاعتقال
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه مساء مين التي اشعلت
شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد الشرطه الاخلاق ووفاتها
في 16 من سبتمبر الماضي
لتمتد تظاهرات اكثر من 150 مدينه ايرانيه
حسب المعارضه على مدار 24
[موسيقى]
الفكره ال 40 لوفاه ماسا اميني قمع
المتظاهرون بعنف او الى ديسمبر الماضي
لاحتواء الاحتجاجات صدر قرار بحل الشرطه
الاخلاق
لمتظاهر في ما ينتظر العشرات مصيرا مماثله
اسعار الذهب والعمله الصعبه والغلاء ستبدا
في التراجع ارتفع سعر الدولار الامريكي في
سوق طهران الحره الى اكثر من 45,000 كمان
مسجلا رقما قياسيا جديدا وكان مركز
الاحصاء الايراني قد تحدث عن ارتفاع معدل
التضخم السنوي في البلاد خلال الشهر
الماضي الى اكثر من 46% وهو اعلى معدل
تضخم اعلنه مركز الاحصاء الايراني في
تاريخ نشر احصائيات مؤشر المستهلك داخل
ايران
اعصار رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعه
السوداني محافظ البنك المركزي مصطفى غالب
مخيف من منصبه وقالت وكاله الانباء
العراقيه ان السوداني كلف علي محسن العلاق
باداره البنك بالوكاله وتاتي الخطوه في
اطار المساعي الحكوميه للسيطره على تقلبات
سعر الصرف للعمله الاجنبيه في السوق
العراقيه
تحالف دعم الشرعيه في اليمن المزاعم
الحوثيه بوجود قصف حدودي على مديرتي منبه
وشد في اليمن واكد التحالف في بيان دعامه
كافه الجهود دعمه كافه الجهود لتثبيت
الهدنه المنتهيه في اكتوبر الماضي وشدد
البيان على ان القوات التحالف تمارس اعلى
درجات ضبط النفس في ظل الاستمرار خلقات
ميليشيا الحوثي
واحبطت الاجهزه الامنيه في محافظه المهره
شرق اليمن عمليه تهريب شحنه من تجهيزات
وقطع طائرات بدون طيار تابعه لمليشيات
الحوثي وذلك في منفذ شحن الحدودي مصادر
امنيه افادت ان الشحنه كانت تضم 25 صندوقا
مموهن تحتوي على نحو مئه محرك خاص
بالطائرات من دون طيار وذكرت المصادر ان
الشاحنه استخدمت وثائق توشير الى انها قطع
غيار تابعه لشبكه اتصالات بينما كانت
الصناديق تحمل شعار هواوي وذلك للتمويه
على حقيقه الشحنه
اعلنت وزاره الطاقه الباكستانيه عن عطل في
شبكه الكهرباء صباح اليوم في باكستان تسبب
في انقطاع التيار التيار الكهربائي في
البلاد حيث كان الانقطاع في العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد وكراتجي ولاهور
ومدن رئيسيه اخرى واكدت الوزاره على انه
هناك عمل سريع لاصلاح شبكه الكهربائيه في
البلاد
نشير مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل امامكم على
الشاشه حيث ان رئيس دونيتك المعين من قبل
روسيا يزور مدينه سوليدار شرقي اوكرانيا
بعد اعلان السيطره الكامله عليها اذا رئيس
دنيتك المعين من قبل روسيا يزور منطقه
سوليدار بعد ان سيطرت عليها القوات
الروسيه عوده الى سياق نشرتنا امر رئيس
جمهيدن الاحد بتنكيس الاعلام الامريكيه في
المباني العامه وذلك تكريما لضحايا اطلاق
النار الجماعيه في مونتري بارك في
كاليفورنيا
حتى غروب الشمس في السادس والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري وذلك احتراما لضحايا اعمال
العنف التي ارتكبت يوم السبت
بولايه كاليفورنيا حسب ما جاء في بيان
للبيت الابيض
بعد ان عثرت الشرطه الامريكيه على جثه جثه
داخل سياره كانت تطاردها خلال بحثها عن
مطلق النار في كاليفورنيا ثم تبين لاحقا
ان جثه الجاني بحسب صحيفه لوس انجلوس
تايمز نشرت نقلا عن مصدر في الشرطه ان
السائق اطلق النار على نفسه عقبه مطارده
الشرطه له من جهته يعتبر قائد شرطه لوس
انجلوس روبرت لونا حدث اطلاق النار احدى
ابشع القضايا في المقاطعه واشار ان
القتلهم خمس نساء وخمسه رجال اضافه الى
جرح عشره اشخاص على الاقل وحاله بعضهم
حرجه وكشف اليمنى ان منفذ الهجوم امريكي
من اصول اسيويه ويبلغ من العمر 72 عاما
كشف تحقيق لجديده البريطانيه عن اختفاء
العشرات من الاطفال طالبين اللجوء في
بريطانيا بظروف غامضه عن اختطافهم من قبل
عصابات الاجراميه
خلال الثمانيه عشر شهرا الماضيه عايشه
حوالي 600 طفل من طالب اللجوء بدون ذويهم
في فندق تديره وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
بمدينه برايتون
تم الابلاغ عن اختفاء 136 منهم
لا يزال اكثر من نصف هؤلاء بما يعادل 79
طفلا في عداد المفقودين
الجارديان
ربما يتم التجاره ببعض الاطفال المفقودين
في اماكن بعيده مثل مانشستر واسكتلندا
وزيره الداخليه
على الحكومه البريطانيه الكشف عن عدد
الاطفال الذين اختفوا وما الذي يتم فعله
للعثور عليهم
[موسيقى]
222 من طالبين اللجوء غير المسحوبين
بدويهم فقدوا من الفنادق التي تديرها
وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
هولندا
من دون المانيا لارسال دبابات ليوبارد الى
اوكرانيا
وزراء وخارجيه اوروبا يبحثون اليوم قائمه
جديده من العقوبات على مسؤولين ايرانيين
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
الاخرى بسبب عطل كبير في الشبكه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]